people in louisiana are filling sandbags
and boarding up windows for the sixth
time
in the last few months alone hurricane
delta is headed their way growing more
powerful and threatening
to hit the state as early as tomorrow
delta barreled through the mexican
resort areas of cancun and cozumel
yesterday
and our lead national correspondent
david bagno is awaiting the storm in
delcombe
that's in southern louisiana david good
morning to you
tony good morning to you welcome to
cajun country my hometown
we are used to hurricanes happening here
but what's different
about this is it could be a repeat
hurricane delta
is as of now projected to make landfall
within 15 to 20 miles
from where hurricane laura made landfall
just six weeks ago in lake charles and
tony you were there for it
that would be incredible if the same
people devastated by laura
get hit yet again but let's start with
what delta did
in mexico we're in a pandemic right now
and knowing that we're going to have
close quarters this whole entire time
with the hurricane trying to figure out
exactly how we were going to
do what we could for our family this is
not what the detallo family from south
dakota was expecting on their vacation
riding out hurricane delta at a packed
shelter in playa del carmen
as the storm slammed mexico with 110
mile per hour winds
the mayor of cancun spoke about fallen
trees and utility poles that were down
which made the roads impassable around
266 thousand customers had lost power
we saw this with hurricane laura now it
is louisiana bracing for
another impact people filled sandbags
wednesday as they prepared to hunker
down
just six weeks after hurricane laura
ripped through this area
as a category 4 hurricane for us to
actually
have to go through this and witness this
again i mean
it's breathtaking jasmine jack lost her
lake charles home to laura
that said he was devastated by the
hurricane and its residents
are still digging out of the wreckage
while we were there we saw construction
crews fixing a roof
as the sun was setting on a warm
louisiana night debris from laura still
litters the streets
windows are boarded up and it is enough
to make people like nathan smith
continue leaving southwest louisiana for
good i've been thinking about moving
and this kind of gave me giving me the
reason to do it
this morning along the louisiana gulf
coast there are mandatory and voluntary
evacuations in place in different places
as we take a look at the radar so you've
got delta in the gulf right now it is
expected to
strengthen to a category three at some
point today but here's the catch
as it gets closer to the louisiana
coastline the water's cooler there
so it's believed that delta will weaken
to a category
two by comparison six weeks ago
hurricane laura was a category four
when it hit this area gail landfall is
scheduled for
give or take maybe five or six o'clock
local time
tomorrow night man david you look at
those stories and you go how much more
can we take
how much more please 2020 enough
thank you very much these louisianians
are a resilient bunch
i know you guys are i know you guys are
david thanks